ALAN SEALES: To perform a
few songs for us now, please
welcome the cast of
"Spring Awakening."
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC - "MAMA WHO BORE ME"]
[MUSIC - "DON'T DO SADNESS"]
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC - "THE SONG OF PURPLE
SUMMER"]
[APPLAUSE]
ALAN SEALES: Keep it going.
One more time.
Cool.
So please go down the line
and introduce yourselves.
And talk about what
you do in the show
and how you got involved.
ALI STROKER: Hi.
ALAN SEALES: Redundant mic?
We need it?
ALI STROKER: Hi, my
name is Allie Stroker
and I play the role
of Anna in the revival
of "Spring Awakening."
And I became involved in
production a year and a half
ago when I auditioned in
California, in Los Angeles.
AUSTIN MCKENZIE: My
name is Austin McKenzie
and I play the role
of Melchior Gabor.
I, too, joined a year ago, when
we did the show in Skid Row,
in Los Angeles.
And I sent in an audition
tape from Chicago
and got cast from there.
SANDRA MAE FRANK
THROUGH INTERPRETER:
Hi, my name is Sandra Mae
Frank and I'm from Kentucky.
I play the role of Wendla.
And so I also sent in a
tape from Washington DC,
where I was at the time.
And I didn't hear anything
for about a month.
And the next thing I knew,
I was out in California
with a whole varied
cast, with a whole bunch
of people that came together.
That was about a year
ago, and here we are now.
Yay.
KATIE BOECK: My
name is Katie Boeck,
and I am the voice of Wendla.
So the show kind of
functions in this cool way,
where the deaf actors
have voicing counterparts,
some of which are
also in the band.
So I play guitar and
kind of shadow her
and follow her
around as her voice.
ALEX BONIELLO:
I'm Alex Boniello.
I am the voice of Moritz,
which is played by Daniel.
And I do basically
the exact same thing
as what she just said.
I play guitar in the
band, shadow him about,
voice for him.
Whenever he's signing.
I'll be speaking
for the most part.
DANIEL DURANT
THROUGH INTERPRETER:
Hi, my name is Daniel, and I
play the character of Moritz.
And yeah, that's pretty much it.
I mean, I myself
am from Minnesota.
I've been involved in the
theater, was out in California,
and now I'm happy to be here.
ROBERT ARIZA: Hi,
I'm Robert Ariza.
I'm one of the swings for
the production of "Spring
Awakening."
And I joined here in
New York, actually.
ALAN SEALES: Wow.
So this was put on, or, I
guess the revival came on,
through Deaf West.
So where did the idea come from?
Are any of you privy to how
the idea even came about?
KATIE BOECK: Well, Michael
Arden is our director,
and I'm pretty sure
that he and Andy, who
is Hanschen in our cast,
had this brilliant idea
to do a production of
this show, which centers
on the themes of basically
the breakdown in communication
between parents and children.
And how, especially when it
comes to sex and, you know,
educating children about that
phase of life of adolescence,
how-- at least in this time
in the show, and even still
today-- how difficult it can be.
Because it's uncomfortable,
it's awkward,
parents don't know how to
talk to their children.
So they had this amazing
idea to revive it
with Deaf West, casting two
of the three main characters
as deaf characters
actually within the show,
to just sort of amplify
that theme of the difficulty
in communicating.
So some of the characters in
the show have deaf parents.
Some of them have
hearing parents.
And so in many of the scenes,
that idea of communication
is really amplified.
And, I don't know, maybe
you can elaborate on that?
AUSTIN MCKENZIE:
Well, actually, we
should talk about
the Milan Conference.
KATIE BOECK: Oh, yeah,
SANDRA MAE FRANK
THROUGH INTERPRETER:
OK, so the Milan Conference
was a gathering that took place
sometime in the 1880s.
Back then, the sign language,
ASL, was readily available.
But at this conference, they
decided to come together
to talk about communication.
And they decided that
they would no longer
allow people to use ASL.
Instead, they would have to use
an oral means of communication.
And that way, everybody
would learn English
and be able to
communicate with everyone.
And if you wouldn't be able
to use your voice or speak,
then you wouldn't make
it through education.
And so that was
happening at the time
the original play
was being written.
So it's kind of
interesting to look
at the parallels
about communication.
And it fits really perfectly.
I mean, even though
it wasn't trying to.
But there's a lot of parallels.
ALAN SEALES: So how did
the success of the show
out there lead it
to Broadway now?
I mean it seems to me--
is that a big leap?
Or is that kind of
like the next step
for what it was-- for where
it was out on the west coast?
ALI STROKER: Yeah, I think
this has been a really special,
unique situation.
You know, we put up this
show almost exactly a year.
Our first show, downtown Los
Angeles, was a year to the day
that we opened our first
preview on Broadway.
And we did two different
performances, or productions,
in LA before we
came to New York.
We did a production
in a 99-seat theater.
And it was kind of like
a black box setting.
It was small and it
was really a time
for us to explore how we
were going to tell the story.
And then that went really well.
We got extended.
It was sold out.
People were really,
really excited.
And then we did it
at a bigger theater
in Beverly Hills called
the Wallis Annenberg
theater this past spring.
And there had been a
little bit of buzz,
like, oh, maybe it
will move to New York,
or maybe something will happen.
And then all of us were like,
we're not getting our hopes up.
We'll see what happens.
And then a month
later, we found out
that we were going to be
opening this fall on Broadway.
And so, here we are.
ALAN SEALES: So Robert, you said
you joined in New York, right?
But the rest of you were all
part of the original cast,
right?
ALEX BONIELLO: I joined
at the second production.
So I wasn't at
the 99-seat thing.
So I guess I kind of got to
miss the hard, hard, hard part.
I kind of just hopped in and
lived my life in Beverly Hills
with these guys.
KATIE BOECK: The
majority of the cast
is almost entirely from
the original version
that we did downtown.
ALEX BONIELLO: Right.
KATIE BOECK: There's been
some changes here and there.
Some of the adults, a couple
of the swings and voices,
and stuff like that.
But almost everybody--
ALAN SEALES: I think all
of you on stage right now,
this is like everyone's
Broadway debut, right?
KATIE BOECK: Yes.
ALEX BONIELLO: Yes.
ROBERT ARIZA: That's correct.
ALAN SEALES: So I just want to
acknowledge that real quick,
because this is
amazingly talented.
[APPLAUSE]
See, the show was
phenomenal and you guys,
I would've never thought
that you had never been
on Broadway before, but--
ALEX BONIELLO: We fooled you.
ALAN SEALES: Haha.
The magic of theater.
And so, on the surface, the
show is about teenagers,
and discovering their sexuality.
And have you found
that a lot of people
come to the show with
different expectations of what
it's about?
Because the friend of mine that
I brought when I saw the show,
she was like, oh,
it's a tragedy.
And I said, oh yes,
you just wait, right?
Do you find that is common
in the feedback that you get?
ALEX BONIELLO: I'm finding
because the first production
of the show on Broadway
was kind of recent--
some would say very
recent-- a lot of people
have ideas of what this
show is based off of that.
And I think that when
you come to see the show,
you realize what we
and our creative team,
and what Michael Arden
and everybody decided
to do with it is a complete
reinvention of what
the show is, right?
I mean, by setting
these characters,
making them actually deaf, it's
not like a theatrical conceit
that there's sign language.
You know, it's actually
part of the story now.
And I think that the
second that people
who have any kind of expectation
as to what the show is
sees what's going on and your
brain takes a minute to adjust,
you're like, OK, so I'm
listening to that person,
but I'm going to watch
the person who's signing.
Then once everything
clicks, I think
you understand what it is
that we're trying to do.
And I think overall,
the reception
has been overwhelmingly
positive.
And that feels very
good for all of us.
I'm sure.
ALAN SEALES: Right.
Well, what was that
translation process like?
How did you approach
this, or the director?
How did you approach this
and say, all right, here's
this amazingly well put
together, finalized show?
And then kind of
open up the surface,
put the sign language
aspect on top of it,
and then put it
all back together?
Because in my opinion,
the original choreography
had a lot of hand movement.
Obviously none of it
had to do with signing,
but a lot of that
original integrity
is still maintained
in your production,
even though the
entire show is signed.
AUSTIN MCKENZIE: I think that
going through the translation
process-- we have four
genius translators.
Let's see, their names,
Linda Bove, Shoshannah Stern,
Anthony Natale, and
Elizabeth Greene,
and they're all geniuses at what
they've done with the script.
All of the scenes, and
the time period, is 1891.
So all of that is almost old
signs that were used back then.
But all of the music is--
ALAN SEALES: So the
signing-- ASL progresses?
SANDRA MAE FRANK THROUGH
INTERPRETER: If I may,
I can expand on
that a little bit.
So just like English
has changed over time,
and it grows and develops, and
some words aren't used anymore,
and new words come in-- the
same thing with sign language.
And so there are different
signs that we use.
I mean, we still do use
modern terms throughout.
But there are some signs
that are done differently
as an homage to that time.
It's the way we
produce the sign.
I mean, the 1890s was a
more uptight kind of area.
So we try to reflect
that in the language
and sign in a proper
manner and what would
have been done at that time.
ALAN SEALES: Proper--
wow, that is something
I never thought about.
KATIE BOECK: The
original production,
though, really made a
distinction between the time
period being very-- the
language being very proper
in the scenes, and the songs
themselves sort of taking you
out of that time to this
modern rock musical score.
So that was a big distinction
in the original show.
So the fact that
that's being reflected
in the sign in this show,
and with the band being
on stage in this show, I think
that is one aspect that we've
been able to really-- because
we know the show is totally
different, we're doing a
completely different thing
than we did in the original.
But that aspect of
it, I think, is really
being maintained
in this production.
ALAN SEALES: So how much
of what is signed actually
corresponds to
what is being sung?
Are the lyrics maintained
in the sign language?
SANDRA MAE FRANK
THROUGH INTERPRETER:
No, no, it's
completely different.
It is completely different.
AUSTIN MCKENZIE: When it comes
to the words of the music,
I mean, as I was saying
before, the scenes
are all pretty straightforward.
The words, they make sense.
It's regular communication.
But when the songs come
about, they're very poetic.
And it's almost Shakespearean.
You might not
understand completely
what they're saying just
hearing it the first time.
You really have
to think about it.
It really challenges
the audience members.
And so with our translators,
the four translators,
they did a brilliant job
with duplicating that essence
of beauty and poetry.
And it's still in sign language.
But you know, like
many languages,
the word order is different.
So you'll be singing a
word, but maybe you're
not signing that word.
Maybe it's flipped int a
different part of the sentence.
Just structurally,
I mean, that's
syntaxually a thing that's not
very exciting to talk about.
But the essence of the
songs, of the poetry,
is still in the sign language.
Daniel, did you want to--?
DANIEL DURANT
THROUGH INTERPRETER:
No, you're doing fine.
You said it all.
SANDRA MAE FRANK
THROUGH INTERPRETER:
You know what, I will
say, as an example,
there's a line from the song
that we did that-- I'm just
going to sign it.
But the line that
talks about signing,
and that I would do a new dance.
OK that's the ASL.
So it's not exactly what
the English is going to be,
but this is what it looks like.
KATIE BOECK: Here is
Sorrow doing a new dance.
SANDRA MAE FRANK
THROUGH INTERPRETER:
So instead of following exactly
what the English words are,
we go for more of the concepts.
And so once people see what
the signs are, and they're
hearing the words, even if they
don't understand each one right
away, it all comes together.
And I feel like the ASL adds
a whole strong layer that
makes it oh so very visual.
ALAN SEALES: So talking
about, I guess, the union
between actor and
voice actor who
is also a band
member-- that adds,
like, two extra
layers, in my opinion,
to what's going on here.
Was the rehearsal
process, or was
the discovery and the creation
of the character different,
do you think, than
that would've been
if you had been approaching
a character on your own?
ALEX BONIELLO: Well,
ours is particularly fun
because, like I said, I
joined the second run.
So he had already done
all this work, right,
on what his idea of
this character was.
And I-- up until, like, a day
before we started rehearsals--
I had never even
met a deaf person.
So we had absolutely no means
of communication whatsoever.
So when Daniel and
I met, it started
with him using his
phone to type to me,
which is the only thing
I had to talk to him.
And so through that,
we would sit down,
we would look at the
script, and before we even
talked about character choice or
what this character's feeling,
he would show me
all these signs.
And you know, I may
not be able to know
exactly what it is that he's
signing in all of our scenes
together.
But him and I have
worked really,
really hard, and
with the ASL masters,
to make sure that we
understand that when he's
on this part of the
sequence of sign language,
that means I have to be on this
word, and things like that.
And then comes the whole
discussion of sitting down
and Daniel will tell me,
this is what is going on
with this character.
Because it's, I would say, like
a 70%-30% collaboration here.
The physical actor needs
to be the one taking lead.
And it needs to be
our job to support
what it is they're doing.
But, you know, again, that
doesn't mean there's not input.
And I'm sure Daniel has plenty
to say about this as well.
DANIEL DURANT THROUGH
INTERPRETER: Sure.
Right.
I think that I don't have
any musical lines at first.
We didn't start with that.
But he can see the
emotion, the energy
and then when it comes to music,
he kind of takes the lead.
And so I follow his
timing and where he
is with the rhythm and whatnot.
Because I can't hear it at all.
So we use cues for one
another, and right, I
take the lead when it's
a non-musical part.
And then I follow
his lead otherwise.
And it is a challenge.
I mean, I don't have a lot
of experience with music,
and I need to learn when to go
faster or when to go slower.
There are different instruments
used at different times.
So these are things
we've worked on together.
ALEX BONIELLO: And
you actually saw it
when we were singing
our song together.
If you notice, I
was tapping myself
just so that he knew when a
certain line was starting.
Because in the
context of the show,
there's a lot more going on,
obviously, than just the two
of us standing there and
me being able to watch him.
There are lights and things
like that that will help him
and then--
ALAN SEALES: What other kind of
cues do the rest of the actors
use?
DANIEL DURANT
THROUGH INTERPRETER:
Well, the choreography
has really
worked with how we're
moving on the stage.
There may be a prop
that's handed off,
or some other movement
or action on the stage,
so that each of us know
that, OK, that's my cue.
When that happens, she takes
a paper, then I do this.
AUSTIN MCKENZIE:
I will say, too,
that I think in this production,
it's not so much of--
and I think it
started off this way,
but as we all kind of grew
together and understood--
and even Michael, I
think, as he started
to explore this and understand,
really, what the show was--
I really feel like the
voice actors aren't just
voice actors.
I think you guys are
your own characters.
People have equated them to the
subconscious of the deaf actor,
or imaginary friends.
I see them as guardian angels.
And it was even a
couple weeks ago
when I have a very
intimate scene with Sandra,
and I didn't realize that
Katie was making choices
and communicating with Sandra.
And I think it's really--
I wish I could see that,
because it's so beautiful.
KATIE BOECK: I think that speaks
to the creative part of working
together.
Because obviously there
are technical things
like making sure her
signs are the same amount
of time as my line.
So that's a very
technical thing.
Or squeezing her
shoulder so that she
knows that-- you know-- we
don't have anything like that.
I squeeze his shoulder, but
for her, any time I touch her,
it's a cue.
I'm not just touching her
arbitrarily to touch her.
It's because I'm trying to
cue her within the song.
So that's all the technical
side of working together.
And then creatively,
I think this
is a really interesting point,
because we have a relationship
on stage, you know?
There are things
we do to ourselves,
you know, in our
own lives that I
now, as her voice and sort of
her subconscious, her guardian
angel-- her angel on
her right, her devil
on her left, whatever--
I'm guiding her
as sort of a big sister figure.
And that, from a creative,
artistic standpoint,
is really cool, because I get to
embody some of her subconscious
thoughts that-- as an actor,
you have an inner monologue.
If you take an
acting class, people
will say, you're
speaking your lines,
but what are you saying
underneath all that?
And I really get the
opportunity to explore
those kinds of feelings.
And if you see the show, there's
moments where we connect.
And it's funny, because
she's looking to me, like,
should I go talk
to this cute boy?
And I'm like yeah, yeah, you
should totally go do that.
Or, should I have sex
with this cute boy?
And I'm like, uh.
And what's interesting is,
part of my exciting process
has been using
the lyric as a way
to inform this relationship.
So many of the songs are in
a past tense, which-- that's
just what the writer gave us.
And so for me, trying to justify
why I'm here on this stage--
starting at the
beginning, I really
wanted to allow Sandy to create
this character for herself,
and without a lot of influence
from the voice inside her head.
I wanted her to have that
opportunity, so I would only
really step in in
terms of, like, here's
what I think this
character would
do if we reached a point of,
what would this character do?
If we really needed to kind
of collaborate on that.
But so much of that has
been honoring her choices,
allowing her to be
free within the moment.
Because there's so many
technical aspects, in order
for her to feel like I can
make new choices every night,
it's really on me to be
focused and following her.
If she wants to take more
time on a certain line,
I can't just do my own thing.
I really have to watch
what she's doing.
And going back to
the point I made
about the lyrics being
in the past tense,
for me, being
outside of it, it's
really been this experience
of a remembrance, almost.
Like, I go through the
show and I'm almost
remembering what my former
self, the choices she's made.
And it has become sort of like
a spiritual aspect of the show.
I think a lot of
people come to our show
and feel like, wow, that was--
because so many of the themes
are religious and spiritual,
and about how the Church has
caused so many people to feel so
ashamed of their human desires.
And so I think having
these voiced in characters
has really amplified
that spiritual element
of the show, at least for me.
ALAN SEALES: Well, I want to do
another awkward transition here
and pull out our n
plus 2 redundancy.
And I found another mic, which
I think belong in the aisles
here.
There we go.
Pay no attention to
the man in the corner.
So yes, if you have any
questions for the cast,
please come up to the
mics here once they're
both on the stands, and
you can talk to them.
Austin, this is not only your
Broadway debut, but apparently
your theatrical debut.
Like, where did you
come from, dude?
AUSTIN MCKENZIE: It's
also Miles-- Miles Barbee
who plays Otto, his as
well-- right over there.
Well, I don't know.
I connect with him
through fear, because this
is such a scary thing to do.
ALAN SEALES: What did
you do beforehand?
Did you do like TV, film, right?
Or were you just like, hey, I'm
gonna sit at an audition table?
Oh, I'm on Broadway.
[LAUGHTER]
AUSTIN MCKENZIE: Well, I
blinked an eye and here I was.
No, I was attending college to
become a special needs teacher,
and I mean, truly, all
this just happened.
And I woke up, and
I'm not sure if this
is some sort of nightmare or
some sort of dream come true.
But you know, it's nice to
have the consistent show
to go to every night, and I have
a family to go to every night,
and I love that.
ALAN SEALES:
Welcome to New York.
Yeah, you've got
the Jonathan Groff
embodiment going on there.
You've been told that
before, you've got the hair?
So I guess speaking of
original cast members,
you were on "The
Glee Project," Ali,
and then you got your role
on "Glee" for a few episodes,
right?
Were you working on this
at all during that time,
like did you talk about this
with Lea Michelle at all?
ALI STROKER: Yeah,
it's very odd, right?
No, I was not involved
with this at all.
I saw Lea do the show on
Broadway when I was in college,
and I had some friends that
were in the original production.
And I never thought
I'd be a part
of "Spring Awakening,"
because I'm 28
and these characters are 14.
[LAUGHTER]
ALI STROKER: But there I was
on "Glee," playing 16, so.
Yeah, so no, they
were not connected,
but it's kind of interesting.
ALAN SEALES: Yeah,
it's very ironic.
You're also the first
person in a wheelchair
to ever be on Broadway as well.
[APPLAUSE]
ALAN SEALES: So yes,
lots of firsts here.
But I want to go
back to the-- what
do we call it-- people
swapping, whenever
there are understudies in.
And that's why, Robert, that's
where you come in, right?
So how many people
do you understudy?
AUSTIN MCKENZIE: He just
went in for our Hanschen
a couple nights ago,
and he was brilliant.
He was genius.
ALAN SEALES: And so he should.
And so how many characters
do you understudy?
ROBERT ARIZA: I cover
four different roles.
I have also never swung before
I started this production,
and all of the
characters that I cover
sign the entirety of the show.
AUSTIN MCKENZIE:
It's an easy job.
ROBERT ARIZA: I've also
never swung before.
I've been an understudy
before, for like one character
in a show or
something, but swinging
for several different roles is
definitely its own challenge.
And I feel like I
was very lucky enough
to come to this point in my
life very prepared for this job,
because I have done two
different productions of Spring
Awakening prior to this.
And actually, right before I
got my audition for this job,
I had just closed a production
of Spring Awakening upstate
where I was playing Melchior.
So it was fresh in my mind,
and I was ready to audition.
And then they called
me back and they
had me do an ASL work session.
And it was two hours of
intense, like, OK, you're
going to learn a scene and a
song for your final callback,
and then kind of prove to
us that you can learn ASL
fast enough.
And it's really hard, because
like they were mentioning
before, a lot of this cast
has been together already
for a year, developing
the show and everything,
and the swings-- I think
almost all of us are new.
We had to learn it just from
watching them in rehearsal.
We didn't really get any special
attention until after opening.
So our first rehearsal
was the Tuesday
after we opened on Broadway.
ALAN SEALES: That's like
a week and a half ago.
ROBERT ARIZA: Yeah.
I had really only one actual
rehearsal for Hanschen
before I went on, because
I went on Monday night.
And I had never been
so under-rehearsed
for a performance ever
in my entire life.
And I've been in performing
for 11 years now.
But the support that I got
from the cast and everyone
backstage, the crew, everyone
was watching out for me.
Whenever I was just
a little bit off,
I would get a little
shove from someone
to make sure I was
in the right spot.
It was very, very
shoved with love.
Every time I came off
stage people were like, OK,
how are you feeling?
How's it going?
And I was like, good, good.
It was just the craziest night.
KATIE BOECK: He also had 100
people in the audience to see,
which was amazing.
We have an incredible cast.
ROBERT ARIZA: So
I'm from New York.
I'm from Queens.
And being from New York, I've
lived here all of my life,
and my family and friends
are all here, basically.
And so I knew that I
had the date on Monday,
that was going to be
my first night on,
from the day I got the job.
And so I told people right
away, get your tickets
for October 5th.
That's my Broadway debut.
And word got around, and I
had about 150 people there
to see me.
It was the wildest
night of my life.
ALAN SEALES: Looks like we
got a question over here.
AUDIENCE: Hi, I just
recently saw the show.
It was great.
I was curious if you could
explain the beginning where
you are all in
your undergarments
and the significance of that.
ALEX BONIELLO: I'm clothed.
I don't--
AUSTIN MCKENZIE:
That's true, yeah.
KATIE BOECK: I think
it's basically--
Michael wanted it
to be like, not--
he didn't want there
to be a time period
to be clear on stage.
And at the end of the
show, everyone also
takes their undergarments off.
So it's really this time where
we come on stage as ourselves,
and we leave as ourselves.
And without--
AUSTIN MCKENZIE: We take
our clothes off back
to undergarments.
KATIE BOECK: Right, yeah.
In the last song--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
KATIE BOECK: We don't
get naked or anything.
We're not nude on stage.
That's a different musical.
But we all have-- everyone
except for the musicians,
which I think is a cool
picture at the end, too.
We're in modern clothing.
The musicians are all in
modern clothing the whole time,
but the undergarments,
I think, serve
as just a wiping away of time.
It's not about it
being set in that time.
It's these themes
are relevant today.
Parents and children still
have trouble communicating.
That's why there's this
big outrage about Planned
Parenthood-- people
need other places to go
to get this information,
because parents sometimes don't
know how to talk to their kids.
And so I think that just
really serves as a device.
ALI STROKER: I'd like
to add something too.
This show is really
an ensemble piece.
We work together so closely,
not just the technical sides
of the signing, but we
have to all be together.
And so that is a moment
before the show starts
where we're all
on stage together,
and we can connect like,
OK, here we go, team.
Let's tell the story.
Let's connect with each
other before we do this.
So I think it also serves
as a moment for all of us.
KATIE BOECK: Right, and
then when Sandy and I come
to the mirror, she
hands me my guitar
and I hand her her
dress, her period dress.
And so I think
that really serves
as a technique to
just illustrate
how the show's going to work.
She gives me the
permission to be her voice,
and I give her permission to
go forth and to tell the story.
And that ends up
setting the stage
without having to
have someone explain.
That does it for that.
ALAN SEALES: So you guys are all
on stage as the house is open,
like the audience is loading in.
How much of that is
choreographed and scripted?
Or are you guys actually
just up there having fun
and being yourselves?
SANDRA MAE FRANK
THROUGH INTERPRETER:
We're just playing.
We're just having fun with each
other, warming up together.
Yeah, it's really
been a great thing
because it helps us to relax.
It helps us to know
we're coming together--
we're working together.
And I don't know
about other people,
but for me it was
like, OK, I'm ready.
Here we are.
I'm putting on this character.
And so no, nothing
of it is planned out.
It's our playing ground
before the show starts.
AUSTIN MCKENZIE: It also makes
you a little less scared,
because that
nightmare where you're
in front of the class with
just your underwear on?
Well, we did it, so.
Every night.
ALAN SEALES: Have you ever
had any weird happening
where you had to hold
the house, and you're
sitting there on stage for
like 10 minutes saying,
why can't I put
my clothes on yet?
ALEX BONIELLO: Opening night.
ALAN SEALES: Oh really?
ALEX BONIELLO: Yeah, a lot
of people who were very fancy
had to arrive.
We knew that was
going to be the deal,
but you're just standing there.
You're trying to be
in the show and not
be too excited, because it's
opening night and stuff,
but then you're like,
ah, there's Kelly Ripa.
Hello.
People are getting
dressed, and then we're
standing there trying to--
but it hasn't been that bad.
KATIE BOECK: It's t-shirts and
boxers, and slips for girls,
so old-timey underwear
is more conservative
than modern underwear,
which is nothing.
ALAN SEALES: I'll go
back to the underlying
message of the
show for a second,
because in the show
you deal with suicide,
and with teenage pregnancy
and abortion, and just
overall general topics
that now are still
somewhat taboo, unfortunately.
Have you had anyone reach out
to you through the show, maybe,
that has voiced
support through you,
or looked for support from you?
DANIEL DURANT THROUGH
INTERPRETER: Well, yeah.
One of the favorite parts
that I've experienced
is afterwards, going
out to meet the fans,
and sign the autographs,
and talk to people.
And there have
been people who've
approached me and talked about
their own personal experiences.
And it's just fantastic
to see the variations
amongst our fans, but the common
threads and the similarities--
the experience of coming through
a dark time and depression.
And for people to be able
to see that on stage,
that has been inspiring
to me to honor that,
and hope that we're reflecting
that in an honorable way.
But yeah, it has
been, to me, to meet
the fans and the
various emotions
that this generates, people
who have experienced loss.
It's a pretty human experience.
SANDRA MAE FRANK
THROUGH INTERPRETER:
And I would also add that
we've gotten letters,
or people on Twitter
or Tumblr, and even
some personal direct emails.
There was one story that a
woman sent about having grown up
hearing and having become deaf
and having to try and learn
sign language, and she
hadn't really gotten into it.
But by virtue of
seeing the show,
she felt like
there may have been
an opening in our
community, and that she
felt motivated to go out
there and learn sign language.
She's deaf, and there's
lots of people out there
who lose their
hearing, but they try
to get through just
with reading lips
and without learning
sign language.
And they never are comfortable.
They never have 100% access.
And so for us to
represent that experience,
that was kind of
heart-wrenching for me.
That was touching.
ALI STROKER: And I'd just
like to add one other thing.
I've had some really
cool conversations
with people in the disabled
or differently-abled community
about how rarely the two topics
of sexuality and disability
are put together.
And that this is a
really unique opportunity
to be able to share
that story, when you
add this other element onto it.
AUSTIN MCKENZIE: I think
the biggest thing is--
so many people come
into this show, I think,
ignorant to this culture that's
alive and well and beautiful,
and I don't think
that it's a tragedy
to be ignorant to something.
I think the real tragedy is when
you continue to be ignorant,
and you choose to be
ignorant to something.
And I think that
for people who have
seen the show who are deaf,
or-- it really doesn't matter.
I mean, for any audience
member in the show, I think,
seeing this production this
way, it's putting forth the idea
that there is a
place for everyone.
Regardless of anything
that has to do
with your physical challenges,
everyone has something.
And there's a place for
every single person.
ALAN SEALES: Right.
Well the closing number that
you guys performed here for us,
"Purple Summer"-- purple
summer is a flower that
only blooms in summer, right?
And I think that's what-- it's
supposed to be metaphorical?
Or is it a literal thing?
AUSTIN MCKENZIE: It's beautiful.
ALAN SEALES: So it's this
flower that only blooms
in the summer, which I
took to interpret-- this
is me reading into
it-- which I took
to interpret as the spring,
everything is just blossoming.
Everything is growing,
but everything
is pretty much time boxed.
So if things are bad, that
basically this too shall
pass, like, it will get better.
Time moves on.
Time heals all wounds.
ROBERT ARIZA: And I think
that's one thing, and through
every iteration of this
show that I've done before--
and I was a huge fan of the
original when it came out.
And it came out a
time where I was
going through a lot of things
that this show just shed light
on.
It just helped me through.
It was like the soundtrack
of my life at the time.
And one thing that's
always been consistent,
one message that has
is that as tragic
as the story is,
when you get to "Purple Summer,"
it's that message of hope.
You have to leave the audience
with that message of hope,
that there is more.
That there is a light at
the end of all of this.
And "Purple Summer" is not meant
to be an ending to the story.
It's a coda.
In the script, it's
written as a coda.
The story ends at the end
of Melchior's last song,
as you know.
And then the actors come out and
tell you what the message is,
of why we told you the story.
AUSTIN MCKENZIE: You
need to experience winter
to get to summer.
ALAN SEALES: Good point.
All right, so if there
are no more questions,
then we are out of time here.
So please help me in
thanking them for coming in.
Thank you so much.